well it's completely scandalous he's
been in a high security prison for 4 and
a half years he's not convicted of
anything he's there because the US wants
to exodite him and there's kind of a
pingpong uh attitude between the UK and
the US the US says oh it's the UK that's
putting him in prison the UK says we're
just putting him in prison on behalf of
the US and uh meanwhile you have someone
who's not convicted of anything uh
languishing in a high security prison
for 4 and a half years and
counting
okay I'm here with Stella Sange the wife
of Julian Assange and I guess the most
uh well the best part to start with
would be that your husband is actually
not too far from here right now yeah
he's about 15minute drive from where we
are um he's near the temps but it feels
like it's miles away from London when
you're there yeah and he is I mean he's
locked up that's that's just the nature
of reality you mentioned to my producer
iard you get to see him twice a week um
and I guess just talk a little bit about
his physical his sort of emotional
sayate then we we'll get into obviously
the bigger stuff but but well not that
much is bigger than that I suppose well
he's been in this high security prison
in um Southeast London since the 11th of
April
2019 um he is locked up in a Cell over
20 hours a day he gets to go to the yard
uh for up to an hour a day it's um on
his wing about 30% of people there are
accused or convicted of
murder uh and you know Julian's not a he
he shouldn't be in prison in the first
place right he's a journalist he's there
because of what he published uh but he's
there because the United States is
trying to extradite him I get to see him
once or twice a week on weekends I go
with our children children we have a 4
and 1/2-year-old and a
6-year-old and all they know is their
father inside this prison space they've
never been in a different room outside
of this uh prison with their father but
that you know the contact that we have
it keeps us both um connected it's
incredibly important we can speak uh
every day we speak several times during
the day he's able to call me I can't
call him uh and the conversations only
last about 10 minutes at a time and I
assume they're listening to the
conversation yeah everything's you know
there's there is absolutely no privacy
when we go to see each other it's in
this big Hall there are about 40 other
prisoners who are meeting their family
and their friends we sit on one side of
a table about the size this size um he
sits on the other I can hug him and I
can hold his hand across a table the
kids can sit on his lap and he can read
stories to them but apart from that he
has to remain seated and um yeah it's a
very obviously very
regimented encounter yeah I sort of feel
like we should do a whole interview just
just on the human part of it because
that's the part that kind of get lost
here but I but I want to use our time as
as effectively as possible so what is
the status of his AAP an overi i is this
now just un up period here in the UK or
or where are you guys at with everything
uh well it's completely scandalous he's
been in a high security prison for 4 and
a half years he's not convicted of
anything he's there because the US wants
to extradite him and there's kind of a
pingpong uh attitude between the UK and
the US the US says oh it's the UK that's
putting him in prison the UK says we're
just putting him in prison on behalf of
the US and uh meanwhile you have someone
who's not convicted of anything uh
languishing in a high security prison
for 4 and a half years and counting the
United States has put in an what do the
UK authorities actually say he's in
prison for for them I I understand
they're saying it's it's because of the
pressure of the United States but they
have to say he's there for something
yeah they say he's a Flight
Risk um so because he previously sought
Asylum and obtained it um in the
Ecuadorian Embassy back in 2012 because
he said the US uh was in the background
maybe going to try to extradite him at
the time there was an extradition
request from Sweden Sweden refused to
give a guarantee that they wouldn't send
him on to the United States so he saw
Asylum and uh and obtained it and then
in
2019 Ecuador uh had changed his
relationship with the United States and
basically sold him out and he got
arrested and he's been in prison since
then what's the resolution that he or
you would want at the moment like if the
phone rang today and you got whatever
you would consider the best news what is
well this case should never have been
brought uh beyond
the you know uh cruelty towards Julian
it is a dangerous case it sets a a
terrible precedent it is an attack on
the first amendment in the United States
um it's the administration was actually
the Trump Administration that that
brought the indictment and um it is an
attack on the on the First Amendment
it's the first time that the Espionage
Act is used against a publisher for
publishing he's literally accused um of
receiving possessing and communicating
information to the public he's not
actually accused of Espionage per se
because the Espionage Act it's this act
from 100 years ago it's really broadly
worded and uh it's basically been
repurposed to criminalize journalism and
the way they that it's been done is to
use Julian um to set the precedent and
because he's uh he's a person who you
know the mainstream media has attacked
for many years and so on uh he was an
easy target but by doing that uh the
principles of free speech that are so
Central to to us society and politics
has been uh fatally undermined so this
this is just a terrible prosecution uh
to bring because it basically
um criminalizes journalism for forever
unless it's dropped so the best outcome
would be to drop it to say actually uh
we went too far this should have never
been Dro uh brought uh but frankly I
mean Julian has been in prison for 4 and
a half years and the principal is
important but I as his wife I just want
him to come home and to be able to be
with our kids and his life is the most
important thing his freedom is the most
important thing for us as a family but
there are of course bigger implications
um for the rest of society for
journalism for free speech of course did
you have a sense that possibly even
though some of this did happen under the
Trump Administration um that possibly he
was going to get pardoned at the end
there was a really big push and Trump
was the sort of I'm going to take out
the Deep State guy um and obviously just
nothing they happened there was there
anything behind the scenes or there was
a a big push I know there were people
within Trump's Administration who were
trying hard I think it was a terrible
sign of weakness by Trump um that he
didn't pardon Julian and that he is now
basically suffering the consequences of
the failure to be strong in that moment
of course the asage ACT is being used
against Trump now and this expansion of
the use of the Espionage Act uh it
actually started under Obama he started
using it against whistleblowers a lot
more often than Trump the Trump
Administration I should say it was
basically Mike Pompeo in the background
who was pushing for it um they then went
from whistleblowers to the publisher to
the receiver information the journalist
and then now it's being used in a in a
political in a like quite a nakedly uh
political manner because this Espionage
Act is so broadly worded and uh it also
changes the culture around the use of
this piece of
legislation are you sympathetic to
people that would say that states have
some right to have state Secrets at at
some level of course I mean I I
understand that uh you know the state
has different um it is a is a
multi-organ
um thing uh and there are different
functions and the state uh has to has an
interest and has to try to keep it
Secrets journalists have to publish
information if it's in the public
interest they don't have the same
responsibility as the state when it
comes to um uh Secrets what what matters
there is whether that secret should be
in the public uh domain because it has
some some significance because it has a
political or legal or um whatever if
it's you know um with the Publications
that licks is accused of uh publishing
this concerned the Iraq and the Afghan
Wars um uh one Tano Bay
Etc you know Secrets secret information
uh often contains information that
uh when when information has been
covered up when wrongdoing has occurred
uh then it's kept from the public and
that's not to say that all secret
information should be in the public
domain um but it is to say that uh it's
just a reality that authorities hide in
information by labeling it secret are
you shocked that more journalists
usually on my show I have to go like
this when I say journalists with the air
quotes that more journalists haven't
taken up the cause of Julian I mean
obviously there's there's some level
that have but I mean certainly from a
mainstream perspective it's pretty much
an on story that that's just kind of how
it is well at an editorial level you
have New York Times Washington Post to
say this case is terrible because they
have their legal department they've
analyzed the case they understand it's
an attack on their ability to publish
things and you know the fact that that
for example the New York Times has has
put out an editorial saying it should be
dropped indicates to me that they have
stories that are just basically left in
the without being published because the
advice they get is look at the Assange
case you can't publish this either
they're going to try to put you in jail
or we're just going to be balked down in
um legal cases for for years and years
and a lot of money and so on so we're
just not going to publish it so
basically there has been a terrible
chill in the newsrooms has that
translated to journalists um not so much
I mean you have some uh you know there
have been segments with some mainstream
uh
journalists uh but it's not talked about
as much as it should be and uh that's I
think down to ignorance on the one hand
uh
basically there was a uh failure to
understand what Wikileaks and Julian was
were about um and that uh the way the US
decided to go after Julian um was as a
publisher they they I think hoped that
if they went after Julian they'd find
some other way of doing it but the truth
is that all he did was basically do what
the New York Times does all the time
which is publish information um some of
it is classified sometimes that
classified information is given to them
by the administration sometimes it's not
right um and so their hands certainly
are not clean in how they deal with
information and when it's political and
when it isn't and what they decide to
release and everything else exactly so
so um but then there's a lot of
journalists who don't actually work in
um who are more of a kind of commentary
sure in the commentary world and maybe
don't understand the the bigger
implications uh but it should be you
know I think it should be clear as uh to
all journalists that um it impoverishes
the public space and the public space
needs like Liberty needs a robust public
space to thrive you need people who are
you know of different opinions um able
to speak freely uh and to disagree and
and uh by putting Julian in prison like
you you kind of um impoverished that
ecosystem dramatically and if you're if
journalists are not able to publish the
most controversial things then you know
we're we're all I mean we're basically
all in a kind of managed information
environment at the moment and social
media has been incredibly complicit in
this and uh you know I think the the the
they're after the public domain now it
started with Julian and of obviously
National Security um highly
controversial uh Publications about War
right um but now it's just um the
opinions of anyone that is being
censored and this is all part of a
spectrum and I think we're you know the
failure to defend Julian in the
beginning has has led to where we are
now yeah do you think if the if the
timing had been a little bit different
had we known as much say through the
Twitter files that Eli released years
before that more people could have seen
the connections between all these things
cuz there's obviously a through line
between the way that big Tech could say
suppress the hunter bite a laptop the
things that Julian was exposing before
years of Co like there's clearly
something that connects all of these
things and that maybe if the timing had
been a little bit tighter that we might
have fought some of this a little bit
differently yeah I think 2016 was a
major moment of uh change right uh in
both because of the election of trump
and the kind of perceived uh shock to
the system this was for the
establishment and the same here in in
the UK with brexit and so uh there was
this kind of recasting of public opinion
as dangerous as something that had to be
managed information has is it has to be
managed and um and and the whole rushia
gate hysteria and of course Wikileaks
was um Accused by the Clinton
administration of having been
responsible for Trump's election this
kind of thing um the DNC even tried to
uh Sue Wikileaks and Julian personally
in relation to the DNC Publications but
uh New York uh the Southern District
Court of new New York uh threw out the
case and this was not talked about uh
because they said publications of the
DNC were of the highest public
importance um you know finding out about
what's happening behind the scenes
during an election period is um the most
important thing that the American public
can can read and this is protected by
the First Amendment you never heard
about this uh because it just didn't fit
the narrative
and I think this is a big problem there
has not been an effective
counternarrative there has been a big um
disinformation misinformation narrative
that was attached to this aftermath of
2016 it's allowed to flourish states
have just loved to throw money at this
um industry of of managing information
managing public opinion uh and uh that's
how we we find ourselves where we find
ourselves and of course Co basically
solidifi all of this and but at the same
time I think the public is a lot more
aware of how their rights are being
undermined uh how how their free speech
is basically uh is is uh there is no
free speech on the internet you have to
find spaces of free speech uh and it's
not transparent how you're being
censored and all these things so I think
uh in one way there is hope because uh
the the awareness of of the attack on
our rights and our liberties is a lot
more widespread and I think it's also a
a one point of hopefully
of encounter between people
self-identify as left or right that
actually there are some fundamentals
that we need to fight for and uh and
we're all going to find ourselves on the
receiving end if censorship prospers so
uh I I think we're in a a worse place
but also a better place in terms of um
identifying the problem how could people
help to get us to that better place well
in the United
States we have to get join and free
people should contact their
representatives uh McGovern and Massie
have done a joint letter to Joe Biden
asking him to drop the case
um uh Congress can representatives from
Congress uh can join the letter and uh
people can call their representatives to
ask them to join the letter please or
any other initiative to to help free
Julian uh there's a aanish defense is an
organization in the US that is fighting
for Julian's freedom and just talk about
Julian's case um follow me on on Twitter
I'm Stella corange and just keep
fighting because Julian really
isn't he's a free speech um he's
dedicated his life to free speech
and to informing the public and he would
do make a very valuable contribution uh
Because he believes in the higher good
of people knowing the truth it's not
about where you stand it's about we need
to Value the truth and be able to speak
it I know that you would prefer that he
was the one doing this interview but
you're an excellent Communicator of his
ideas so I thank you for your time
thanks if you're looking for more
uncensored opinions from today's thought
leaders check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell